today the Matt wall show Ben Shapiro
traumatizes the nation's podcasters by
attending a podcasting convention Mark
Zuckerberg reveals that the hunter Biden
laptop story was suppressed at the
behest of the FBI an investigative
report proves that children's hospitals
are in fact removing the uteruses from
physically healthy children Gavin Newsom
says that conservatives are big mean
bullies and the Scientific American sets
out to debunk the existence of males and
females we'll see how they do all of
that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
the Consumer Price Index has reached a
yet another 40-year high in the latest
GDP numbers confirmed the United States
is in a recession despite the fact that
our current Administration is trying to
redefine what recession means during the
2007 recession Washington Mutual Lehman
Brothers Chrysler multiple Blue Chip
stocks went down to zero overnight could
that happen again if so how confident
are you that your savings are protected
well now's not the time to have all your
money in the stock market or tied to the
US dollar take action today to protect
your savings from a highly turbulent
economy by diversifying at least some of
your Investment Portfolio into gold and
silver from Birch gold text Walsh to
989898 and Burch will send you a free
information kit on how to transition an
IRA or eligible 401K into an IRA in
Precious Metals Birch gold will even
help you hold gold in a tax sheltered
account for decades investors have
relied on gold and silver as a hedge
against inflation now you can do the
same with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau you know that you
can count on Birch gold now uh so all
you got to do is text them at text Walsh
to 989 0.98 and get help real help from
Birch gold today again text Walsh to
989898 to claim your free no obligation
information kit on how to protect your
hard-earned savings with gold
well as you all know I am nothing if not
a sunny cheerful Optimist I prefer to
believe that we live in a world of
rainbows and gumdrops that's just how I
like to see the world and that's why
when I encounter abject lunacy and
absurdity I still sometimes have a hard
time believing believing it you know
believing that it's true there's a part
of me that clings to the hope the
desperate dying hope that the dumbest
most incorrigibly stupid things are
really just a joke a dark kind of satire
yet those hopes are almost always in the
end dashed and that brings us to the
events of yesterday afternoon but before
we get there we gotta back up a little
bit the day the day before yesterday
when the podcast movement conference
kicked off in Dallas this is a trade
Expo for podcasters organized and run by
a group called podcast movement uh
podcasters from around the country they
come together and they they talk about
podcasting now frankly as a podcaster
myself
the event sounds like a nightmare like
the last thing I'd ever want to do is
beer around a bunch of other podcasters
talking about podcasting that's just me
you know the daily wire had a more
positive attitude about it and so the
company sent set up a booth on the
convention floor to be clear we paid to
set up a booth the money was accepted by
this group podcast movement and uh the
booth was set up and everything seemed
to be fine
until tragedy struck
Ben Shapiro showed up at the conference
now he wasn't speaking there he wasn't
presenting anything he just kind of
showed up and uh said hello to people
took some pictures with fans and then he
left
as far as I know he didn't lash out
violently at any point he didn't go
berserk and and start murdering
podcasters left and right and even if he
did you know there are so many
podcasters in the world that honestly it
wouldn't be that big of a deal we have
enough to spare but that's not what
happened he also did not despite reports
of the contrary uh bite the head off of
a kitten while uttering demonic
incantations he didn't even drink blood
or breathe fire he did none of those
things so far as I'm aware
and yet podcast movement the next day
issued this tweet which when I saw for
the first time I could only stare at it
blankly for several minutes trying to
convince myself that it's supposed to be
satirical but alas it is not they
tweeted
hi folks we owe you an apology before
before sessions kick off for the day
yesterday afternoon Ben Shapiro briefly
visited the PM 22 Expo area near the
daily wire booth though he was not
registered or expected we take full
responsibility for the harm done by his
presence
there's no way around it we agreed to
sell the daily wire a first-time Booth
based on the company's large presence in
podcasting the weight of that decision
is now painfully clear
Shapiro is a co-founder a drop in
however unlikely should have been
considered a possibility
oh but they aren't done yet it continues
those of you who call this unacceptable
are right in nine wonderful years
growing and celebrating this medium pm
has made mistakes
the pain caused by this one will always
stick with us we promise that sponsors
will be more carefully considered moving
forward just to clarify no TW TDW
representatives were scheduled to appear
on panels and Shapiro remained in the
common space and did not have a badge if
you have questions we're here to talk
thank you for reading and we hope you
continue to join us from here on out
now In fairness I will admit that Ben's
presence in the office causes uh me pain
and Trauma as well but that's only
because he stole my giant stuffed
wallers if any of the people of the
podcast conference even have giant
stuffed walruses theirs were home safe
and not threatened by Ben Shapiro at all
so what was their complaint
well a short time after these tweets
from the podcast movement went out the
daily wire released video from Ben's
brief time at the conference so you can
watch for yourself and decide
whether this reaction from the people
there was warranted so here's the
footage and of course you know it goes
without saying viewer discretion is
advised here it is
yesterday afternoon Ben Shapiro briefly
visited the pm22 Expo though he was not
registered or expected we take full
responsibility for the harm done by his
presence
[Music]
thank you we agreed to sell the daily
wire a first-time Booth based on the
company's large presence in podcasting
the weight of that decision is now
painfully clear
[Music]
all right
[Music]
during event planning the dangerous
nature of the company's messaging was
overlooked
[Music]
those of you who called this
unacceptable are right podcast movement
has made mistakes the pain caused by
this one will always stick with us
thank you so much I appreciate it thank
you I'm excited about it that's great
[Music]
thank you
my God he's a monster
those people certainly look like they
were fearing for their lives because
that's what you do when you're deathly
afraid of somebody you ask for a selfie
um may seem to be sort of an unorthodox
strategy but it turned out to be an
effective defense mechanism perhaps it's
a tactic you could try the next time
you're being chased Through the Woods by
an Ax Murderer you can stop them from
killing you by just asking them to pose
for a picture
now in any event clearly not everybody
was happy to see Ben there uh one
podcaster who goes by the handle star
planes on Twitter took a picture of Ben
from a safe distance and tweeted it with
a caption hey podcast movement what the
f
continuing it says as a trans a queer
person as someone with a uterus this
does not make me feel welcome this does
not make me feel safe
a short time later starplanes provided
this update just confirm what the Pod
move team that they did not know Shapiro
was attending in fact they were told he
was not him showing up was the first
they knew about it does that make
everything okay no am I much happier
knowing he was not an invited guest
absolutely
now you might be asking yourself who
gives a damn what starplanes thinks why
is she special was Bench Bear supposed
to get special clearance from her
specifically before simply existing
within a 100 foot radius of her
well yes that's exactly what was
supposed to happen apparently
and that's why due to this complaint
from Star planes and maybe a few other
complaints though that's the only one
I've actually seen
the organization issued what may go down
in history as the most pathetic apology
of all time
it certainly wins the title for this
month at least I think we can agree on
that
now what makes this all the more
pathetic and embarrassing is that Ben
Shapiro is one of the very top
podcasters in the business the daily
wire as a company is one of the top
podcast Publishers according to the
latest ranking from pod track we're the
sixth largest publisher
in the country with 72 million downloads
just last month last month alone which
means we beat companies like Disney and
fox and Paramount and cumulus in fact
our performance is even more impressive
than that as as uh padrack counts us as
having 12 active shows I Heart Radio
which is the number one publisher has
678 active shows wondering at number two
has 202. NPR at three has 46.
so we come in at number six with only 12
and less than half of those 12 are daily
shows so pound for pound in terms of the
average number of downloads per show we
actually should be number two right by
the New York Times
the point here is that if you're a
podcaster
attending a podcast and Convention with
podcasting talks and workshops
you should want us there you should be
coming up to us for podcasting classes
you should be asking us to teach our
secrets if you see Ben Shapiro walking
around you should be coming to him for
advice not running away in fear with
your hands over your ears
star planes whose real name apparently
is talminir is in the podcasting
business and yet nobody's ever heard of
this person
she's had no success
her career has been pitiful no offense
but she didn't go to Ben Shapiro and say
hi I work in the same business as you
but I have no idea how to be successful
at it you are much much better at this
and approximately five million times
more successful please teach me your
ways
now if you want to be successful that's
what you do when you're around people
who are more successful than you in the
same field instead she stood off at a
distance tweeting angrily and demanding
that this man who could teach her so
much be escorted off the premises
and and maybe as I say this I'm kind of
explaining part of the problem there is
no doubt a lot of jealousy at work here
the deli wire is conservative but that
alone is not our our sin right our sin
is that we are conservative and wildly
successful that's why they can't stand
Us in fact they're more than happy to
have conservatives who are in these same
spaces but are not successful
that's good
but to be successful in their space and
to be more successful than them that's
that's just not that's unthinkable
and yet as ridiculous as all this is
we cannot fail to notice the more
serious implications
so
it's bad enough when a conservative is
judged dangerous or harmful for the
opinions that he's expressing
it's bad enough when our ideas are
treated like chemical weapons
what happened yesterday represents an
escalation beyond all of that
it's not simply Ben's opinions that are
dangerous now it is his presence his
existence in physical space is harmful
and painful
now I don't think I need to spell out
why this is you know
why this is a problem
when it's determined that a
conservative's mere presence can cause
harm
the stage has been set for some rather
dark and terrible things
and if I do need to spell it out then I
will say that labeling the physical
presence of a group of people harmful
is pre-genocide talk
it is quite literally a justification
for rounding people up and throwing them
in prisons or mass Graves
and if it was just some group of fragile
podcasters talking this way it'd be
nothing to worry about but the problem
is that this is increasingly the
language adopted by all of the most
powerful institutions in America
that those with wrong ideas are not just
wrong
uh they're dangerous they're terrorists
and they have to be dealt with
accordingly
and that's where all this leads
now let's get to our five headlines
well from cringing at the pump to
getting an eye-popping check at your
favorite restaurant inflation is hitting
us all where it hurts and it really
hurts that's why I started using upside
upside is an incredible app for anyone
who buys gas if you buy groceries if
you're dine out so this is just
everybody right with every purchase I'm
earning cash back thanks to upside
upside is incredibly easy to use I get
cash back every time I fill up on gas
and even at certain fast food
restaurants and coffee shops it's not
too good to be true it really works you
got to try it to get started download
the free upside app use my promo code
tmws and you'll get um five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
ten dollars or more next you can claim
an offer for whatever you're buying on
upside check in at the business pay as
usual with a credit card or debit card
and get paid that's how easy it is in
comparison to Credit Card Rewards or
loyalty programs you can earn three
times more with upside upside users are
earning more than a million dollars
every week I mean collectively not
individually but still it's a lot of
money that's probably why they have a
4.8 star rating on the App Store
download the free upside app and use
promo code tmws to get five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
ten dollars more that's five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
ten dollars or more using promo code
tmws
you know the other reason of course why
they're afraid of our presence is that
these people all Harbor ideas and
opinions that um they simply cannot
defend
and they know they can't defend them so
here's another good example of this
also from yesterday Andy no
uh you all know who Andy Noe is he
tweeted a year ago okay this was a year
ago
he put out a tweet about Alana
McLaughlin who's an MMA fighter a male
who beats the hell out of females
a year later
I guess having taken 12 months to think
of a comeback
McLaughlin's trainer who goes by the
name Elias Cepeda responded to Andy no a
year later and says
that's right and I'm damn proud to train
her you cowards coming for her can come
for me as well I'm easy to find
and again he's just responding to Andy
no pointing out that there is this male
MMA fighter Alana McLaughlin who's
beating the hell out of female
and then
the guy's trainer comes and says Ah you
why don't you come say that to my face
right
well I saw this and uh rather than
taking another year to continue the
conversation I decided to speed the pace
up a little bit and I responded to him
and I said is this challenge open to
anyone I'd love to talk to you and give
you the opportunity to defend your
position on transgenderism and women's
sports also would love to get your
definition of the word woman let's set
it up
I thought you know this is a tough guy
he was just he was just tweeting say
anyone can come for me bring it
and I said okay let's do it we could we
in person you know we could set
something up whatever you want to do
well it took him a day to get back to me
uh pretty fast turnaround for him so
he's working a little bit faster give
him some credit for that um took him uh
you know it only took him a day to put
put this together and he says
I don't defend or debate that trans
women are equal to CIS women and
deserving of equal rights professional
opportunities and Pursuits of Happiness
anyone wanting to challenge that is
denying a group of people's humanity and
I don't treat such people as good faith
actors
of course of course you don't you
pathetic gutless little coward
you absolute wimp
and of course people in the comments
some of his supporters were saying oh
well he didn't mean challenge to a
debate okay what kind of challenge was
he talking about
but punching we could punch each other
I mean I would fully admit if you're an
MMA fighter and we got into a contest
about who could punch the other person
better he'd probably win that fight
the problem though is that that wouldn't
do anything to prove the legitimacy of
your ideas
okay
um and if you're interested in that
especially if I'm a bad faith actor I'm
uh I'm just a bigot my ideas are totally
indefensible right and that's what you
believe
why would you
forgo the opportunity to humiliate me
how easy if I'm just a bigot bad faith
actor I I you know I hate trans people
how easy would it be to totally
humiliate me
we sit down for across from each other
no it could be a live stream no edits
just you could you could utterly
embarrass me
and especially if you have if you have a
definition for the word woman
that still validates your you know your
point of view
I've set this whole challenge up around
what is a woman if you could actually
answer the question how embarrassing
would that be for me
doesn't want to take advantage of the
opportunity interesting
see that's the on their side see for me
on on this side being on the right side
I will talk to literally anyone I am not
afraid to talk to any I don't care who
you are
pulling any expert doctor scientist I
don't care I'll sit down and talk to you
anyone
on their side they take the exact
opposite approach they won't talk to
anybody
they don't even want to be in the same
room
all right let's start here daily wire uh
has a report meta CEO Mark Zuckerberg
revealed Thursday on The Joe Rogan
Experience that the FBI approached the
social media company during the 2020
presidential election and pushed them to
crack down on alleged Russian propaganda
before the hunter Biden laptop story was
published by the New York Post
Zuckerberg made the remarks when asked
by uh host Joe Rogan how Facebook
handled big news items that were
controversial we actually have the clips
let's play uh let's play some of that
how do you guys handle things when
they're a big news item that's
controversial like there was a lot of
attention on Twitter during the election
because of the hunter Biden laptop story
yeah so you guys censored that as well
so we took a different path than Twitter
um I mean basically the background here
is the FBI I think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was we we thought
there was a lot of Russian propaganda in
the 2016 election we have it on notice
that basically there's about to be some
kind of dump of of um uh that's similar
to that so just be vigilant so our
protocol is different from Twitter's
what Twitter did is they said you can't
share this at all
um we didn't pause there for a second
the first question you hear that so the
FBI went to Facebook and said
be on the look for look out for
misinformation why is the FBI dealing
with this
I mean leaving aside for a moment that
the so-called misinformation they're
suppressing is not misinformation and is
actually true information
even leaving that aside what what is
what the FBI have to do with
misinformation on people are saying
wrong things on the internet and that's
a that's an FBI problem now we need the
Federal Bureau of Investigation to
investigate
wrong opinions on the internet if that's
what the FBI is doing then they could
never do anything but that
because the internet is full of wrong
opinions
but for some reason the FBI is involved
Let's uh keep listening what we do is we
have um
if something is reported to us as
potentially
misinformation important misinformation
we we also have this third party fact
checking program because we don't want
to be deciding what's true and false and
for the I think it was five or seven
days when it was basically being
um being determined whether it was false
the Distribution on Facebook was
decreased but people were still allowed
to share it so you could still share it
you could still consume it so when you
say the distribution is decreased it got
shared how does that work it basically
the ranking in news feed was a little
bit less so fewer people saw it than
would have otherwise so it definitely by
what percentage I don't know off the top
of my head but it's it's it's meaningful
but I mean but basically a um
a lot of people are still able to share
it
we got a lot of complaints that that was
the case
um you know obviously this is a hyper
political place
he thinks that this was this was the
better approach so uh he's proud of the
fact that well we didn't take it down
Twitter
infamously took the story down uh I
think right they suspended the New York
Post for for a period of time for even
posting at the beginning and uh you
weren't allowed to share it at all and
uh even if you try New York Post
couldn't couldn't put it out
and and no other accounts could put it
out that's how Twitter handled it Mark
Zuckerberg says no you were allowed to
share it we just uh we manipulated the
news feed so that fewer people saw it
and this is supposed to be better I
guess he thinks
but if anything it's worse because at
least on Twitter
um what they're doing is out in the open
the bias is out in the open everybody
knows it
and at the very least we can say that
doesn't make it okay or any better but
uh it's it's a public thing we all know
they're doing it
when you're manipulating it behind the
scenes so no one even knows that you're
doing it that's a lot worse that's more
Insidious
not better
but that still doesn't answer the
question of uh why the FBI was getting
involved to begin with and and well we
know the answer to that question
because the FBI was
interested in making sure that Democrats
won presidential election
I mean the FBI is going to the
social media platforms and telling them
what sort of information they're
supposed to suppress on their platforms
this is election rigging
yes the 2020 election was rigged in part
by the FBI according to what we just
heard there
it's a huge Scandal I mean this is a
this is actually an enormous
mind-blowing scandal
but you know what else
no one's going to be talking about it
45 minutes from now
it's a huge Scandal that uh well the
mainstream media doesn't want to talk
about it at all
but in general people will just move on
from it a day later not even talk about
it anymore
do you remember the Trump rate remember
that remember that back from ancient
history and that was the biggest story
in the world across right wing and
left-wing media biggest story
unbelievable the FBI rated Trump
if this is going to change the outcome
of the midterm elections like the
midterm elections are going to be about
this now everybody thought
three days later no one's talking about
it nobody
that's one of the great problems I think
we face as a society and uh it can't all
be pen I mean part of it is the media
you know the media likes to move stories
along quickly especially if they're
stories that aren't favorable to their
agenda so that's part of it but it's not
just the media it's really it's it's
like this is a this is an everybody
problem
where we can't stay focused on one thing
for more than a day
and so
stories and issues that are really
important
um they'll get the attention they
deserve for a brief sliver of time and
then the next day it's like okay what's
the new thing I'm already bored
all right
um
and having said that now I'm going to
move on to the next story okay Gavin
Newsom in California had some thoughts
about Ron DeSantis
especially after DeSantis insulted elves
Yesterday by comparing fauci to them and
uh just uh Gavin Newsom didn't like that
well he was offended for a different
reason let's listen to him
I don't like bullies
you want to ask what my why is in life I
don't like bullies I don't like people
to mean people I don't like people talk
down to people I didn't like what
DeSantis said about fauci that he may
disagree with him but to call someone
pejorative terms because they're short
and who the hell raised these guys
what kind of people are they
I mean I know I always had a you know
sit there and suck it up and take
Trump's demonization but not everybody
has to act like him
I mean literally I I remember growing up
and folks would have their mouths washed
out with soap if they talked like this I
got four kids I don't want these guys
being models the attacking LGBT
community attacking women I mean this
guy's so extreme you rape and incest
Rhonda Santos talks about freedom
and a young girl is raped by her father
doesn't have the right to her own body
to make her own decisions
spare me Freedom there's no Freedom
there's no choice so yeah I'm standing
up as a human being got to use those
dollars and I hope others of you send
money to send a message that uh if
that's the future of the damn Republican
party this country is in real trouble
I like how by the end it just devolved
into the shouting talking points at
random so it started relatively
coherently relatively but by the end
he's just like I mean
LGBT community women
bigotry extreme rape and incest Freedom
climate change
he's like some kind of woke baby doll
where you press his stomach and he says
a program phrase only the doll's
malfunctioning now
as for the stuff at the beginning about
being a bully
well you know sure
I'm I'm actually okay with that yeah I
think
when you're on the side accusing the
other side of being a bully it means
you're losing
that's that's that's the loser claim
in politics
yes people coming out calling Rhonda
Santos a bully that's just that's just
that is a sign of his success
that's what the losers do oh you're
being a bully you're being mean you're
losing
if that's your if that's your criticism
and you know what yeah you're right
see this is this is the new right as
opposed to the the old establishment
right
and on the new right yeah we're gonna be
bullies and we don't care if you call us
that
because we're not going to put up with
it anymore
and we also don't care about the labels
that you use
we don't care if your feelings are hurt
we don't
and we're also we're not going to give
you respect you don't deserve
why did Ron DeSantis talk about fauci
that way because fauci deserves no
respect at all
he has no respect for him
I mean fauci should be in prison he's
not going to be in prison so the least
we could do is insult him well he
deserves it
you don't like that kind of language
right okay deal with it
I don't care
so we're drawing hard lines here
and yeah maybe we're going to be um
we're going to use tougher language than
what you're used to hearing from the
other side because well you're used to
from the other side is that you could
say whatever the hell you want
and insult your opponents the kingdom
come
and they're not going to respond in kind
because they're too worried about Bill
we're going to be dignified
but for them dignified is is the same as
just being a coward they they don't see
a difference between the two
we're not playing that game anymore
so yeah we're being bullies
you deserve to be bullied
and um
well they could get away right with with
insulting the other side all they want
because their insults are oh you're
you're a racist you're a bigot you're
this and that
and that doesn't that doesn't count as
an insult because that's I guess you
know what the media says that's just
that's just an accurate that's an
accurate description
so that's how they see it right that's
really how they see it
they can say whatever they want about us
and treat us any way they want to
because we deserve it that's the
difference
so they can say something about us
and then we could say the exact same
thing about them
and they have the right to be offended
wow because you talk this way well back
in my day you get your mouth washed out
with soap even when you talk the exact
same way but in your mind say they
rationalize it by saying well yeah but
you deserve it you're a terrible person
but you can't say that to me I'm perfect
and for so many years they've gotten
away with that
because the right by and large has just
cooperated
as if to agree
as if to agree that you know what yeah
you deserve more respect than you give
us
what no
those days are over
I hate to tell you Gavin
uh who by the way you look a little bit
like an elf too I just thought I'd note
all right I want to make sure we have
some time for this Libs of tick tock
doing some investigative journalism
um
one of the only people in the country
doing actual investigative journalism
and and what she's doing here is uh
you know you would think that if they're
a real journalist working for these
supposed news outlets that one of them
would have done this
given that we're there's this
conversation about children's hospitals
and so-called gender affirming surgeries
or procedures
and which of those procedures do they
inflict on minors
and which do they reserve for adults
well a good way to find out is to just
call them not as a member of the media
but just call them and ask
that's exactly what Libs Tick Tock did
and uh let's start going through this
audio here this is what by the way this
is the I don't know if I mentioned this
is the um Children's Hospital
what is this Children's National
Hospital in DC okay
thank you for calling National Hospital
your call may be reported
insurance I was calling uh for
information about gender affirming
hysterectomies okay it's a gender
forming history I've been in touch with
quite a few hospitals
um and a lot of them will they said they
won't do it for for my 16 year old
um and then I was told that this
Hospital night and I also saw it on your
website
um so if you guys do uh do it for 16
year olds all I would be happy for you
know to come for a consultation or
whatever it takes
the operator and I hate this craft for
you I just I just need to want to know
if if you guys do service that age you
know before obviously before coming you
know coming all the way for an in-person
consult and going through all the
paperwork yeah it depends each
Department's different some departments
cut off for 18 how old how old is your
patient 16.
okay all right so they're in the clear
I'll email about the call and see what
we can in the meantime if you still want
me to transfer you I still transfer the
service all right so pause it there for
a sec
so we've already heard from the operator
oh well she said it very clear you're in
the clear at the age of 16 you're in the
clear
now this is very different if you were
to call
uh and this is the investigation that
media Outlets have done
where as members of the media they call
the hospital's PR department
and say hey uh you're being criticized
for doing this awful thing do you
actually do that thing and then the
hospital say no no we don't do that
and then the media says well you see
there it is
they would never lie to us
end of discussion
but if you call them
as a potential patient slash customer
willing to give your money you get a
very different answer uh conversation
continues let's play a little bit more
of this
hi I was calling um because I'm looking
for information about the gender
affirming hysterectomies that you guys
offer
am I in the right place okay yes
um this is the clinic did you want to
make an appointment so I was just
wondering I've I've contacted quite a
few hospitals already
um it seems like it's difficult to find
one that does the operation
um for my 16 year old and I was told
that you guys do do that
um so if you do it for 16 year olds then
yes I'd love to schedule an appointment
a consultation whatever you need if you
don't mind me asking
um
what is your child gender change into so
I can point you to the right direction
pause it every second
what did your child's gender change into
this is someone at the hospital at in
the relevant Department asking that
question
what did your child's gender change into
what
what does that mean
and and by the way so it's like because
they're right there's not just two
options
so hysterectomy means that we're dealing
with a girl we can assume so maybe the
hospital worker knows that much
but she's not a girl anymore but maybe
not a boy she could be something else
uh
and it's also like why why does that
matter to you
I mean is is there what what difference
does that make
anyway let's let's continue yeah well he
transitioned to a male you know he
already had the top surgery
um and now we're looking for the
hysterectomy okay beautiful so I'm gonna
transfer you to the GYN nurse line one
of the nurses will give you a call to
give you more information and to let you
know the steps and the protocol that
they do for that okay okay so so they do
so they would do it
um for at for that age
yes
all right there you go that's it good
so confirm with two people the hospital
operator and then someone in the
relevant Department
yes they do gender affirming quote
unquote hysterectomies for 16 year olds
right there from the horse's mouth so to
speak
now uh this was published and shortly
after that
Children's National Hospital put out a
statement
and here's their statement
we are aware of the audio recording
circulating on Twitter here are the
facts
we Foster a welcoming and inclusive
environment for all serving our lgbtq
plus patients and families in the full
spectrum of their care
we do not provide gender affirming
surgery for anyone under the age of 18.
we do not provide hormone therapy to
Children before puberty begins
care is individualized for each patient
always involves families making
decisions in coordination with a team of
highly trained Pediatric Specialists
now once again the media is taking that
and saying well she debunked
we have on tape
the people at the hospital saying yes we
do that for 16 year olds
so
either
the hospital is lying now in an effort
to cover their ass which by the way
that's the correct answer here or the
people at the hospital were lying
someone's lying the hospital the
hospital is lying one way or another the
person who wrote this statement was
lying or the people at the hospital had
uh that you heard in the clip there they
were lying
I mean does the hospital have a policy
against doing gender affirming
hysterectomies for 16 year olds and yet
they were going to do it anyway
well that's a scandal too I mean no
matter what you the hospital doesn't
come out clean here
and you have to kind of hopeless feeling
that you you get as always is that even
though it's right there plain as day it
just doesn't matter there's no
no further investigation from any
relevant Authority this is in DC okay
uh the mayor of DC is not going to put
any pressure on this the police aren't
going to show up
and really the entire statement is
mind-boggling
um
what about this part here we do not
provide hormone therapy to Children
before puberty begins
okay
what what's the significance of that
you don't provide hormone therapy to
Children before puberty begins
but you do provide it after puberty
begins or when puberty is beginning
they're still children though
aren't they
this is something that I've heard from
trans activists actually not the first
time this is something I've heard
frequently over the last few weeks
especially as they've been denying that
this that these things are done to
children at all
and I've heard this well this isn't done
to Children this it doesn't happen until
puberty
what do you mean but so we're talking
about 11 and 12 year olds or even
younger they're not they don't you don't
you don't see them as kids
well the answer is they don't
and now you start to get the full
picture maybe you start to understand
what's really going on here
and this is how this all gets wrapped in
with the normalization of pedophilia the
reason why that is happening kids at
drag shows and all the rest of it the
sexualization of children the
normalization of pedophilia this is all
happening at the same time as the gender
affirming surge of so-called gender
affirmary surgery all this is happening
it's all it's all part of the same
program
because you can hear them saying it
right there it's like well well actually
you know 12 year olds aren't even
children
as you can see they're setting the stage
here
and then let's also keep in mind and I
think it's important to expose the fact
that they're lying about the
hysterectomies and I'm glad that we have
this investigation that confirms that
but let's also not allow them to make
the whole conversation about the
hysterectomies because it is probably
true that most Hospitals and Clinics in
America at least officially don't
perform these that particular procedure
on minors
that's probably the case
um at least not officially
but
that is only a small
portion of the overall picture here
they all do Top surgery they all do
double double mastectomies on kids all
of them do
that that's not any better
so what they're saying is we will
mutilate certain parts of the child's
body but not but then other parts we
wait until you know they're right when
they turn 18.
that is not better at all that that is
that is not a good excuse not even close
to a good excuse
so let's not let they they want the
whole conversation to be focused around
the hysterectomies because they feel
like they're on the safest ground there
although the whole concept of gender
affirming hysterectomy is horrifying uh
they know that like generally that is
that they do wait till 18 for that
they don't want to talk about the top
surgeries
because they're doing that to 13 year
olds
all right one other thing I've had here
on the docket for a while I wanted to
mention a Boeing 737 belonging to
Africa's largest airline remained 37 000
feet in the air when it was supposed to
be landing at its intended destination
earlier this week reported reportedly
because the pilots had fallen asleep Air
Traffic Control officials attempted to
contact the pilots multiple times when
they noticed that the Ethiopian Airlines
plane flying from Sudan to Ethiopia
wasn't descending but the crude failed
to respond and then it turned out that
they had fallen asleep and eventually
they a few minutes later they did
actually land the plane now
um the reason I mention this this is
actually a serious problem
of uh Pilots falling asleep at the wheel
as it were and you know you've always
had the pilot exhaustion's always been
an issue but especially recently even
more so
and you hear this from pilots in fact in
this daily wire article they go on to
talk about the overall problem of uh in
the airline industry in America and
across the world of pilot pilot pilot
exhaustion Pilots being overworked
um this is a big problem especially
recently I I told you about you know a
few months ago I was at an airport and I
heard two pylons complaining about this
I was sitting at the airport listening
to these two pilots complaining about
how tired they were and how overworked
they were
and I'm listening to this and I'm I'm
becoming a communist on the spot I'm
like you guys need to organize Workers
Unite give me a picket sign and I'll
I'll march with you because when it
comes to Pilots my attitude is please
just give them everything they want pay
them millions of dollars give them lots
of time off Pete bootage got six months
off uh from maternity leave despite not
doing anything in his job
I mean airline pilots deserve at least
as much
mental health breaks okay for them
I say give them everything they want
meet every demand I want Pilots to be
well rested and happy that's all I want
I only want well rested very happy and
satisfied people flying the pen the
plane that I'm in
whatever it takes
but the problem is that there that there
is this pilot shortage
and um which is only con you know
exacerbating the problem of pile
exhaustion
and part of the reason for that we're
told
is the pandemic you know we're still
recovering from the pandemic but it's
not actually the pandemic it's it's the
the pandemic response as always
is contributing to this problem
um and what happened well
during coven you may remember that
taxpayers gave as a gift that we had no
choice in we hadn't we had no choice in
this but we we were required to give a
gift to the airline industry billions
and billions of dollars in airline
industry bailout
we were told we had to do this was if we
didn't the airline industry would
collapse and then we wouldn't be able to
travel anymore and it'd be a total
catastrophe
well the airline industry they took all
that money
and they were supposed to use it to
retain staff that's the reason we gave
it to them
so you didn't have a whole bunch of
Pilots quitting and everything you don't
have anyone left to fly the planes
but instead they did the exact opposite
and they used the money as Retirement
packages for Pilots to to incentivize
early retirement and so a whole bunch of
Pilots just retired and took the money
and ran and now we don't have enough
people to fly the planes and the people
that are left are being overworked and
they're totally exhausted
um
and you know eventually there's going to
be there's there's going to be a plane
is going to crash a lot of people are
going to die eventually because of this
and it all goes back as always
you know it's a combination when when
bureaucracies Collide you have the
airline industry bureaucracy colliding
with the with the government bureaucracy
and it creates problems just like this
as always
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
all right before we get into this you
know we've been following the dramatic
story of walrus gate and I told you
yesterday that this Scandal goes right
to the top
um and bench beer is already getting a
lot of heat
and I don't mean to add to it but but I
am going to add to it because his
producer sent me this this is a totally
real I guess he was he was asked about
at some point about the giant walrus and
um
this is a totally real hot mic moment
that was sent to me
I can't tell you who I can't tell you
who my source is but here it is
hey Ben do you know where Matt walrus is
no
he's getting pretty upset about it tell
him to get the [ __ ] back to work
that hurts I
I know I understand I actually
understand I take back everything I said
at the beginning of the show the whole
monologue I retracted
I totally understand how the people of
the podcast convention felt
it's painful
uh
let's see
Luther
what the hell was that
the studio is actually physically
falling apart at this exact moment
what was that
hopefully it wasn't the roof caping in
all right maybe you'll get to see me die
on camera that'd be an interesting
show
probably my most viewed show ever and my
last one uh Luther sunspell says Matt
your analysis of the emptiness social
media of social media Obsession and The
Emptiness it brings was spot on I
avoided social media for a long time due
to having a stalker but then recently
dipped my toe in using pseudonyms I've
noticed just using Twitter can depress
me when I get called a bot or a troll
however you did say women don't get over
stabbing their friends in the back until
they're 60 or 70. so you're canceled
this is like saying all men are perverts
after the 80s because Michael Jackson
was
um I don't think I said all women stab
each other at the back I just you know
there's there's a certain like
ebb and flow to female relationships
with each other and that's it it's an
ebb and flow I think you would agree
um as in terms of social media yeah this
is the thing if you if you
you know we all have this internet
addiction almost all of us suffer from
it to one extent or another there are a
few exceptions but most of us suffer
from it if you pull yourself away from
it though
you pull yourself away from like when
you're when you're in when you're in the
flow of it you you feel this constant
compulsion to pull out the phone check
social media but if you pull yourself
away from it if you go on vacation or
something you go stay at a up in a a
lake house or in a mountain where
there's no where there's no signal and
you don't have access to the phone for a
week or two weeks you come back and it's
like you have to almost you almost are
forcing yourself to get back into the
internet world and so you have this
Moment of clarity where you see how
empty and pointless this all is but then
that just it dissipates pretty quickly
and now and you're sucked right back
into it again
it's a sad story but that's the way it
goes um
Nana and epaw says quick question
regards to the mountain backdrop will
you be changing it for each season what
are you talking about
well if the season changes then
obviously you're going to see the
background change
the completely real background
um
Jesse says did Matt just say clout you
sir are unfortunately banned from your
own show well no I think that clout
chasing is a useful modern phrase first
of all clout is not a modern term okay
that's existed for a long time but clout
chasing is it's one of the few modern
terms internet lingo that I'll use
because I think it's useful it's even
more useful than a virtue signaling I
think as a term
um Emily says Matt
you're a media guy and you come off
extremely out of touch on the student
loan issue I'm not a Biden fan at all
but student debt has been a huge problem
and I'm grateful for the relief I think
a lot of people feel the same way
Republicans need to change their
messaging on this topic ASAP
okay well you so you're
you're what you're saying your argument
if I can call it that is that you
personally benefit from it you know
you're getting ten thousand dollars
shaved off of your loan and you like
that
because it means you owe less money
and that's your argument that's not an
argument like I I understand that from a
kind of self-centered perspective
you're getting ten thousand dollars okay
but do you see how that's not really an
argument
the fact that you personally enjoy
getting this money is not
that's that's not a it's not a
justification for the policy
and that does nothing to address
the objections that I and others have
raised
and the objections are largely well it's
a lot a lot a lot of it has to do with
the economy inflation but it's largely
centered around the burden being felt by
other people
so you what you are saying is Well I
personally care more about my own
Financial Security than other people
I get that
but from a policy perspective you have
to take into account everybody not just
you Emily
as far as Republicans changing their
message I I don't actually don't
disagree with you there
um
I think one of the reasons why
Republicans
lose
on this topic and so many others but the
Republicans are losing on the student
loan
uh question
student loan forgiveness part of the
problem is that Republicans tend to
support you know
Reckless spending bailouts let's send
billions to to Ukraine most Republicans
are on board with that
and so they don't have the credibility
to criticize this kind of spending I you
know Republicans always Republicans
always complain about spending but when
they're actually in charge they don't do
a damn thing about it ever
and so yes it does make them less
credible when they raise objections to a
student loan bailout
but that's just an argument for being
more consistent it's an argument for
opposing
more forms of government spending
not simply accepting this form of it
is it ironic to make an ad for an
ad-free viewing experience maybe well no
it's not it's not an irony is but that
anyway that's exactly the type of
experience you'll get when you subscribe
to daily wire plus this is our growing
hub for all things daily wire where
you'll find shows and podcasts like this
one plus movies bonus content and coming
soon kids content also Daily wire plus
is everything you love about lyr plus
plus so much more and you can uh you
don't get the ads either so you get you
get much more less ads go to
dailywireplus.com to become a member
today and get 35 off your new membership
that's dailywireplus.com now let's get
to our daily cancellation
foreign
we cancel the publication called
Scientific American now the Scientific
American has been around for a very long
time since the mid-1800s in fact it's
one of the very oldest media outlets in
the country and for much of that run it
was considered credible and reputable a
trustworthy source for science related
news a great number of famous scientists
have written articles for it over the
years even Albert Einstein could be
counted among its contributors
but those days are over Albert Albert
Einstein is long dead and if you were
not dead today he would wish he was
because the far left religious cult has
infiltrated and corrupted nearly
everything in society especially the
media and the field of science so if you
combine those two things in a scientific
media Outlets you're sure to get the
worst of Both Worlds and that is
certainly the case with Scientific
American case in point this week the
outlet debuted the the second episode in
their docu-series titled a question of
sex
in a tweet Thread about the series
Scientific American makes clear that the
purpose of the documentary is to debunk
the myth of the two Sexes the myth they
say
yes sexual dimorphism one of the most
fundamental concepts in human biology
and something that no credible scientist
anywhere in the world ever in history
have ever questioned is now a myth
in an article on the website about the
documentary it's explained that the sex
binary is false
because of the existence of intersex
people we're told quote intersex is an
umbrella term for variations in
reproductive or sexual anatomy that may
appear in a person's chromosomes their
genitals or internal organs and it has
been estimated to include about 1.7
percent of the population there are more
than 30 medical terms for different
combinations of sex traits that fall
outside of the typical male and female
passive development
now the article goes on to explain that
the alleged existence of these 1.7
percent of Internet intersex people
throws the whole notion of the sex
binary into question
the article ends with a quote from a
so-called intersex activist named Sean
sifa wall and it says after all the
fixation on a sex binary in science wall
points out doesn't occur in a vacuum
quote I think for people asking the
question is your child a boy or a girl I
would really challenge them to just take
a moment and ask why why is it so
important are you just happy to have a
baby are you just happy to start a
family I think those are quality of life
questions that often get overlooked or
missed in this conversation
yes why do you care if your child is a
boy or a girl
why do you care if your child is human
why do you care about any of the basic
physical details of your child
why can't you raise and parent him as if
he was a an ambiguous non-descript lump
of sentient matter
pretend that he's just an amorphous
puddle of cells in DNA that's all that
matters
makes perfect sense
a clip from the documentary provides
more
um completely imaginary by the way
details let's watch
while gendered social structures are
ancient a binary framework of biological
sex didn't actually exist in Western
culture until the late 18th century
before science recognized only one sex
the male and considered the female body
an inferior version of it
the shift that historians call the two
sex model served mainly to reinforce
gender and racial divisions by tying
social status to the body
okay so let's go over a few things here
first of all we must always keep in mind
that the only reason anybody ever talks
about intersex is to validate
transgenderism that's the only reason
Scientific American is running this
series it's the only reason they Jam
intersex onto the pride flag it's the
only reason they include intersex in the
LGBT alphabet soup intersex is a medical
condition that has nothing to do with
LGBT
but it's included and in fact given
pride of place simply because people who
suffer from this particular genetic
deformity are useful to the trans agenda
never mind the trans and intersex have
nothing in common
and that the existence of intersex
people does not even come close to
validating the claims and
self-perceptions of trans people but
it's important to understand why they're
talking about intersex at all because
then it makes sense
um why they lie about it so much
for instance in the passage from the
article that we read
they say 1.7 of people are intersex
now if you're a person with common sense
you hear that figure
and you feel immediately skeptical
1.7 percent
really I mean that's still a minority
percentage-wise but that would translate
to like six million people in this
country alone are there really six
million intersex people walking around
in this country
well no that number is a lie because
everything these people say is a lie
they lie with abandon about everything
all the time
Colin Wright looked into this uh this
subject a couple years ago and
discovered that the 1.7 percent figure
comes from a book written by a woman
named Ann Fausto Sterling who had an
ideological ax to grind she wanted to
disprove the sex binary and she did it
by wildly inflating the number of
intersex people that exist in the world
reading from rights column it says they
broadly Define an intersex person as
quote
an individual who deviates from the
platonic ideal of physical dimorphism at
the chromosomal genital gonadal and
hormonal levels to arrive at their 1.7
figure they asked how frequently humans
deviate from this platonic ideal in the
review their ideal male is defined as
somebody with XY chromosomes
functional testes located in the scrotal
sac a penis between 2.5 and 4.5
centimeters at Birth and a completely
enclosed urethra that opens at the tip
the ideal male must also have testes
that produce malarian inhibiting Factor
as well as testosterone and um
dihydrotestosterone there we go and
juvenile testicular activity must result
in typical masculizing puberty their
ideal female has two X chromosomes
functional ovaries that result in normal
feminizing puberty intact oviducts
attached to a functional uterus cervix
and vaginal Canal the ideal female must
also have labia minora and Majora
present and a clitoris that ranges from
0.2 centimeters and 0.85 centimeters in
length at Birth
okay
you see the problem hopefully
they are including in their definition
of intersex people
um people who deviate from their
definition of the platonic ideal and yet
whose sex is not at all ambiguous or in
question so they came up with what they
consider to be the platonic ideal of
maleness and anyone who deviates from it
slightly is intersex
so a male
who is clearly and unambiguously male
and yet has a smaller penis than normal
penis or problems with the testes or the
urethra ends up counted as intersex by
their definition
this is just completely ridiculous
and that's why if you apply a more
precise definition of the word intersex
you find that the actual number of
intersex people is lower than
.02 percent that is 100 times less than
the estimate Scientific American
provided
and when you realize that the actual
intersex population is so minuscule the
attempts to use it as a chainsaw to cut
to Pieces the sex binary become even
more obviously ludicrous intersex people
are anomalies they suffer from an
unfortunate medical condition their
existence does not destabilize or throw
into question the notion of biological
sex as we've always understood it
we are still left in a world where
everybody in principle either has the
capacity to get pregnant or the capacity
to impregnate others
now disease deformity or old age May
interfere on an individual level with
those capacities but the principle
remains
just a few days ago I read a story about
a
a two-headed kitten that was born in
Arkansas
now it's an interesting and sort of
grotesque medical anomaly but does it
mean that we can no longer say kittens
have one head
must we now Define kittens as creatures
with multiple heads
must we start talking about kittens like
their mythical beasts like a kitten is a
Hydra from Greek mythology
no of course not
now what about the claim in the video
that the sex binary didn't exist until
the 18th century and before that there
was only one sex well
um that's just pure fiction that's
invented on the spot and with nothing to
support it
read literally anything anything at all
I mean seriously anything
written at any time before the 18th
century and this claim falls apart all
at once the Book of Genesis was written
thousands of years ago and yet says at
the very beginning male and female he
created them
indeed every ancient religion has an
account of creation and they all account
for the creation of males and females
not one sex not three not seven not 52
not an infinite variety but two
because that's all there was at the time
or is now or ever will be
now I would say more to debunk this
particular claim but it would be like
trying to debunk the claim that
watermelons are actually dragon eggs and
if you sit on them a baby dragon will
hatch
it just there's not much that can be
said to refute a purely fictional claim
invented out of whole cloth and with not
the slightest bit of evidence to support
it worse than having no evidence
actually all of the evidence we do have
and there's a lot of it directly flies
in the face of what they're saying
everything we know about ancient history
and about past and current non-western
cultures confirms Beyond any shadow of a
doubt that the sex binary is not a
modern Western invention gender fluidity
is the modern Western invention and it's
now being peddled by a magazine that
once concerned itself with science
but now would rather tell Fables
and for that reason
Scientific American is today canceled
and that will do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the member
section hope to see you there if we
don't talk to you uh on Monday Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]